il ya un vrai tabou dit autour des
personnes de petite taille quand vous
avez vu toute cette affaire vous est-ce
qu'à l'école vous étiez discriminer ce
que vous sentiez mal ouais ouais comme
la plupart comme la plupart des enfants
malheureusement atteints de pathologies
qui fait qu'on a des petits tas et
d'autres maladies
c'est vrai que quand du moment qu'on est
à l'école tant que tant qu'on ne quitte
pas sa scolarité ça continue après quand
on devient adulte ça continue aussi dans
la vie d'adulte dans le cecos vous
entendez sais quoi qui vous dérange
enfin c'est quoi est-ce que vous vous
sentez de regard des gens qui est
curieux sur vous vous sentez il ya des
insultes qui a déjà des moqueries alors
il ya beaucoup de vire d'accord
énormément derrière montauban qu'un
personnellement énorme et rentre dans
mon dos quand je passe devant les jours
dans la rue et ça avec le temps
forcément les reconnaître au sexe à nous
aider jay et c'est très douloureux c'est
vraiment et effectivement il ya aussi
des gens qui vont avoir plus de culot et
qui vont avoir les shows de vous
insulter à coeur ouvert comme ça il ya
des gens qui vous insultent et déjà des
quoi ça a été des petites insultes comme
notre jardin où ça pouvait partir tout
cas très loin après ça a été des
insultes vraiment j'ai pas à certains
moments de la vie j'ai été traitée
vraiment comment pire qu'un animal parce
que même un animal on ne peut pas le
traiter comme c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui
vous arrive et qu'est ce que vous
faisiez vous faisait quoi en fait
c'était quoi les exemples mais c'était
donc des insultes après c'était de me
rabaisser en permanence des fêtes dès
que j'essayais de faire quelque chose
comme tout le monde comme les gens de
mon âge on me stopper net en fait parce
que d'après comme j'étais petit j'avais
paroisse de faire comme ce n'était pas
possible
les gens ne pouvaient pas accepter de
voir faire les choses comme un thé petit
a pas le droit que tu fermes ta bouche
malheureusement est un tueur est on
comprend que vous êtes mariés vous êtes
fiancée vous avez je suis fiancée et je
n'ai pas d'enfant vous êtes sûr c'est
avec une personne qui détaille avec une
personne aurait deux taille normale
drame à 2,90 à huy dans sa voix
et grands lui il a craqué sur vous mais
je comprends je le comprends pas ce que
proscrit vous êtes magnifique non je dis
donc c'est vrai elle est magnifique ça
rigolait gentil et est en chemin on
pense on jouait la question pour ses
potes tout ça comme voilà qui skie comme
il voudrait présenter comment ça s'est
passé
bah il m'a présenté comme en présente sa
copine normalement voyait pas il ya
quand même eu deux voilà non non non ce
que moi c'est ça ce que je te je
voudrais dire et toutes les personnes
atteintes d'un voile à de petites
tailles lourde voilà ce qu'ils veulent
c'est juste être traitée normalement
c'est à dire être voilà donc pas être
traitée différemment mais voilà on sert
malheureusement c'est c'est un possible
cessez jamais possible même dans le
travail même dans la douleur général
c'est pas possible
cette chanteuse je suis chanteuse
d'accord vous chantez quoi d'ondés dans
des soirées dans des noms jeu va je suis
dans une agence actuellement donc là on
a fini en album et après oui ça m'arrive
feront chanter en tient là où l'on
verrait l'album va le faire écouter
mais le problème est aujourd'hui vous
sentez comment est ce que vous sentez
qu'il ya moins de moqueries ou sont et
que c'est pareil quand il y en a
toujours autant
après moi je pense que quand on devient
adulte ont mûri forcément d'accord donc
c'est personnellement c'est plus ma
priorité je pense que j'ai plein
d'autres belles choses à faire au lieu
de penser à un rythme en attaque par les
critiques par les moqueries cessa
entendre j'en entends ton temps je vais
je vais sortir de chez moi je vais
marcher dans la rue je vais avoir 3 4
d'heure d'office des petites mèches
basses et des petits et vire à droite à
gauche mais quand je rentre chez moi le
soir je vais pas m'apitoyer là dessus
j'ai ralenti alors il ya l'option whedon
qui parlait lui c'est pour ça que ça
fait un buzz énorme qui parient de
suicide est-ce que vous au moment où
vous êtes dit voilà je suis trop de
moqueries je subi trop de voix là de
deux colis bs que je vois la chose je me
dis rien dit alors j'ai eu une période
bien sûr à l'adolescence ouais alors moi
j'ai jamais eu
c'est vrai que j'ai eu des idées noires
j'ai eu pas mal d'idées noires mais j'ai
jamais essayé de passer à l'acte ou mais
ça a été très très dur à l'adolescence
parce que c'est là qu'on prend
conscience de ce qu on est des cons
prendre conscience de ce qu'on saura
plus tard